[Music]
today's question comes from brendan in
rhode island brendan writes i've worked
hard for eight years after completing
graduate school at age 23.
i paid off 14 grand in 2 loans and a 13
000 car note i'm 31 now and i make 100
grand a year as a cpa i have 80 grand in
cash 140 in retirement savings i bought
a condo on which i owe 122 at 3.15
i'm doing well but i could be doing
better i have money hoarding issues
which are debilitating even on smaller
purchases i worry about money more than
i should for my level of success my
investments are 15 in bonds because i'm
afraid of a dip and cannot bring myself
to invest in excess cash a six-month
emergency fund for me would be 15 to 17
grand how do i get myself out of this
hoarding and fear in order to boost my
financial success
i
right off the top here man this question
i'm doing well but i could be doing
better
often folks get tied up in this
elusive
place where they're going to quote
unquote feel a certain way whenever they
get to some sort of finish line
and most of us don't take the time to
articulate to ourselves what that
feeling is going to feel like and so we
make our first million i haven't made
one but
then you just you're so obsessed with
the next one because you never stop to
think you think this is going to heal
you right and you don't ever get there
and so i'd love this to ask to sit back
and say what are you chasing what are
you running from where do you think
you're going to be what's it going to
feel like when you get to wherever you
think you're going
because this person is just on a
treadmill hitting up and up and up and
up and up
and yet very intellectually self-aware
brilliant
self-aware yes because the language
you're using says you know
that that you're but i can't believe
it's that you're not that you're not in
a good place and it's nothing to do with
the math it has nothing to do with the
money it's a spiritual issue that's
right
godliness with contentment
is great gain
i want you to kind of what i would tell
you to do is to step back and say let's
start viewing money
through a spiritual lens
through a
a behavior lens
that says
all right i've got to put it over there
it's a tool
i'm not freaked out about my car my car
is a tool that gets me to my job and
gets me to the store and i don't sit and
worry about and obsess about my car
money's a tool it's taking me somewhere
it's a vehicle it's taking me somewhere
and it's sitting over there
instead of it's in my heart
hoarding is a word you use if it's in
your heart
and
this is all it's like it's got its claws
in you yeah and so the peace that passes
understanding
is what we're looking for i want you to
reach a place where the money is sitting
over here and you're looking at it in a
pile smiling at it
and breathing in cool mountain air
and that sense of
exhale and just kind of
okay all right and that's contentment
for me as a spender
brendan what i i i experience that a
couple different ways one way i laugh
about when i experience it is
i used to think when you went into
costco or sam's that it was federal law
you had to spend 200 that's why they
checked you going out with the thing
they want to make sure you spend your
200 right i i just i it was a frenetic
need
to buy something
i think and it wasn't a sickness i
wasn't obsessive compulsive but it was
just a it was a spiritual maturity thing
and it's like oh if i get that i'll be
better if i get that i'll be better if i
get that'll be better
and what you were talking about a minute
ago john and so uh
something happened and uh
when i walk in there now i don't i can
buy anything in there or everything in
there and i don't
buy any of it and leave quite often yeah
and so it's just that that's a i put it
over there your safety your safety
target has moved yeah it's where what
i'm trying to you're asking money to do
something it can't do right
it can't give you peace
it can't give you wholeness it can't
give you
uh no risk there's no such thing and so
when you do that that helps and then
you know
john always says when you're dealing
with trauma that facts are your friends
and so let's let's look at what's real
here yeah okay and you say okay what's
real is bonds are going to underperform
in your portfolio and you're actually
going to make a mess
instead of actually made good money on
something that has a very long
stable track record i mean there are
mutual funds that are 80 years old that
have had eight down years in 80 years
and
72 up years so
to fret over that kind of track record
is to fret over real estate going up or
let's let's call that what it is if
uh mutual funds go away
you'll be dealing with much bigger
issues in your life yeah right you'll
you'll be borrowing water from your
neighbors so there'll be a bigger need
for you need bullets and others
right you'll be trading blue jeans yeah
so yeah so so
you know yes you need to
loosen up i i think you're trying to
make the money due to
it's a warm blanket do something
spiritually for you that it doesn't have
the capability to do and you mentioned
the word trauma often it's been a while
since i've been in the hoarding
literature but
if i remember correctly a lot of
hoarding stems from loss or from trauma
that hasn't been dealt with and it's
just your body's way of trying to grab
control of something until suddenly that
control takes a hold of you well and the
truth is one thing money can do is it
can give you a pad yeah between life
and
you know problems i mean you know if the
car blows up and you've got some money
it's a different than if the car blows
up you don't have money so the truth is
it does control the can helps you
control the controllables but what it
cannot do is it cannot make you breathe
that cool mountain air into your soul
and so this sentence i'm doing well but
i could do better i want you to spend
some time
where are you trying to go
like where is this this imaginary finish
line and what do you think it's going to
feel like when you get there
just spend some time with that breathe
that air and i love that dave larry
burkett used to say that the only
difference between saving and hoarding
is attitude huh
the same amount of money yeah yeah and
it's the same action yeah it's how it's
how tight you're holding you right now
it's attitude it's how you feel
about the money and what you're asking
the money to do for you is it gonna save
me protect me keep me warm and fuzzy at
night that's a hoarder that's exactly
right yeah and that's i need you know so
i can't get rid of this stack of
magazines that i've had for 73 years you
know i'm a hoarder and you know your
house looks like a a dump because you
can't you can't get rid of this stuff
because it's supposed to do something
for you that it doesn't have the ability
to do so this weekend i had i had a suit
that my granddad gave me before he
passed away
and it fits me
but it's a it's an older cut so it's not
something you could wear
um i say it fits me it doesn't fit me
great but it did and i've kept it i've
never put it on in a decade other than
just to
just to try it on once or twice and this
weekend i started i was cleaning out the
old closet and i started to get rid of
it and i was like no this is my granddad
suit who passed away and i finally said
my granddad is not in this
ill-fitted old suit he's here yeah right
and it's time for this to go because
this was i was trying to get this suit
traditionally to be a memory it's not
its job it can't do stuff it's to get me
out of a bank if you give it that job
it's going to fail at it every time the
money's going to fail that's right at
making you feel that cool mountain air
into your soul financial peace is an
attitude it is not an amount
yeah
a load amount that's the thing that's a
good question great question man very
good question